y un último adiós con un funeral de
estado envueltos en la bandera italiana
los ataúdes con los cuerpos del
embajador en la república democrática
del congo y de su guardaespaldas fueron
despedidos en roma luca atanasio de 43
años y vittorio y jacobacci de 30 fueron
asesinados el lunes cuando viajaban en
un convoy del programa mundial de
alimentos de las naciones unidas- cerca
de goma el chofer que los transportaba
mustafa mi lambeau también murió el
recién nombrado primer ministro italiano
mario draghi también acudió para
presentar sus respetos a los familiares
en duelo
y estos hermanos decidieron cómo es ser
comprometerse a ayudar a los demás si
incluso si eso significa sacrificar sus
vidas
la propia vida
el cardenal que lideró la ceremonia
religiosa dijo que estas muertes
deberían llevar a escuchar el llamado de
los habitantes del congo devastado por
la violencia la república democrática
del congo anunció que pondría a todos
los medios posibles en la investigación
mientras tanto en italia el gobierno
exige respuestas por parte de las
instituciones internacionales al
programa alimentario mundial
hemos pedido oficialmente el programa
mundial de alimentos y a la onu que
abran una investigación para aclarar lo
sucedido las razones de los dispositivos
de seguridad utilizados y quienes fueron
responsables de estas decisiones también
hemos explicado que esperamos respuestas
claras y completas en un plazo muy breve
terminar tiempo posible
reese postear en la autopsia realizada a
los cuerpos tras su regreso del congo
sugiere que los dos hombres murieron en
un intercambio de disparos en lo que
habría sido un intento de secuestro
[Música]